marine le pen instigatrice d'un système
de détournement de fonds c'est ce qui
ressort de cinq années d'enquêté 98
pages de rapports rien d'étonnant pour
cette ancienne députée européenne sophie
montel venait tout juste d'être élu
quand elle assiste en juin 2014 selon
elle à l'élaboration de ces embauches
fictive d'assistants parlementaires la
présidente du r n en aurez directement
bénéficié en recrutant son garde du
corps comme assistant parlementaire
thierry légier était payé 9000 euros
brut par mois pour 85 heures mensuelles
est ce que je peux faire garde du corps
de marine le pen moi franchement c'est
beau merci sophie montel d'être avec
nous et ex députée européenne du
rassemblement national
d'ailleurs vous étiez front national
parce que ça s'appelait pas encore
rassemblement national vous êtes au
coeur de cette affaire puisque vous avez
dénoncé les agissements du rassemblement
national et jean beitia est avec nos
anciens membres du rn fondateur de
l'institut apollon alors vous juste s
quel est votre sentiment là-dessus
gilles verdez pour moi c'est une enquête
à charge une enquête politique donc doit
elle rendre l'argent non 98 pages d'
enquête cinq ans on dit que c'est 7
millions d'euros à peu près 6 millions
et comme par hasard ça sort au moment
des élections régionales un an de la
présidentielle
c'est évidemment sorti pour des raisons
politiques on verra sur le fond pour le
moment c'est des détournements présumés
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai mais en
tout cas le fait de sortir maintenant
pour moi c'est trop à charge et ça va
servir marine le pen repris l'examen les
jardins du monde trois ont pris de la
coke je suis très étonné non mais je
suis je serai donc de son oui c'est mais
pour un bon pour ta lucidité alors lui
vient ici des tribunes
à la sophie montel quand vous entendez
ça vous lui dites quoi il les relais ce
que vous étiez au coeur du réacteur
ouais mais ça moi ça ne me surprend pas
que ça sorte sur ouche à un coût c'est
un coup c'est un coup c'est de bonne
guerre j'allais dire je pense que si
marine le pen est présidente de la
république avec elle avait la
possibilité de gêner un certain nombre
d'adversaires bon en même temps c'est
une façon de les remettre aussi sur le
devant de la scène voilà c'est bobo
boussès bausière c'est vrai c'est ça
drama sera un moment choisi oui on met
ça c'est pas grave que ça sorte en plus
il ya quand même eu la crise sanitaire
et avec la crise ducobu qui fait que la
justice a quand même eu des difficultés
à faire avancer ces enquêtes et
investigations il ya quand même ce
facteur là vous confirmer qu'il y avait
bien un système de détournement de fonds
européens mise en place le rassemblement
national
ah bah moi ce que je confirme c'est ce
que j'ai vu c'est que j'ai écrit vous
avez vécu de l'intérieur
vous pouvez alors nous sommes élu le 25
mai 2014
député européen le 4 juin 2014 le
parlement européen invite les nouveaux
conseillers les nouveaux députés
européens à venir au parlement à
bruxelles pour remplir toutes les
paperasses toutes les tous les
formulaires administratifs se faire
tirer le portrait on récupère des badges
et ainsi de suite
et à l'occasion de cette ce déplacement
à bruxelles
le bureau de marine le pen en profite
pour inviter les élus les nouveaux élus
à faire une réunion de travail entre
guillemets sur bruxelles
donc une fois qu'on a fini les
paperasses avec les fonctionnaires du
parlement européen on se retrouve dans
une salle de réunion avec marine le pen
les nouveaux députés européens du
rassemblement du front national à
l'époque on se distribuent ont choisi
quelle commission à toi tu irais à telle
ou telle ou telle commission
et puis un moment donné il ya marine le
pen qui dit qu'il fait qui demande à
certains membres du staff puisqu'il ya
des assistants qui existent qui sont
toujours en poste de mandat en mandat de
quitter la salle donc il s'exécute reste
charles van houtte qui est le
responsable du staff au niveau
administratif
il ya tous les vaincus t il ya tous les
députés fl traitement est là elle nous
dit écoutez contrairement aux
conseillers régionaux et rennes enfin fn
qui reversent une partie de leurs
indemnités
les députés européens s'ils ne sont pas
soumis à cette règle est là en revanche
chacun d'entre vous à 10,9 à dépôt
pouvoir disposer résistances
parlementaires dont les frais
d'assistance parlementaire pour les
frêles assistance parlementaire non pour
embaucher les assistants parlementaires
elle elle nous dit vous aurez droit d'en
désigner un elle reste de l' enveloppe
sera mis à disposition du front national
pouvait pas choisir vos collaborateurs
en fait voilà c'était alors ça ça paraît
très étrange depuis
enfin quand on entend ça c'est vrai
qu'on est dans un moment d'euphorie on
vient d'être élu tout le monde il est
beau tout le monde il est gentil mais
quand même ça crie qu'il ya un certain
nombre de gens voient là la dragée il
commence à coincer au niveau 2 au niveau
de la gorge
bon et la réunion suivante qui se fera
en septembre à strasbourg nous fait
signer une procuration qui auto rose qui
autour d'une configuration en blanc qui
autorise monsieur van houtte continue la
bible en août n est donc qu il a fait
toute une balle sur le chocolat voilà
[Rires]
son signe cette procuration est en fait
cette procuration il permet à monsieur
van houtte de vérifier les taux des
crédits de chacun des députés
je vais le dire cinquante charles a la
possibilité de vérifier la façon dont
les crédits les cris et les crédits sont
consommés pour chacun des députés
européens
alors si nous ça ne nous a pas été
présenté comme ça ça nous est présenté
charles c'est un pilier du groupe
il est là depuis quasi des lustres donc
il connaît parfaitement les rouages du
parlement européen il va vous être d'une
grande utilité vous vous débarquez vous
n'y connaissez rien le parlement
européen vous savez ça fonctionne c'est
très spécial
alors faites nous confiance en gros on
va tous gérés pour vous et puis ne vous
inquiétez pas dormez tranquille donc en
fait il nous est présenté comme le
monsieur lesieu loyal du au parlement
européen pour le pour le groupe
à l'époque ce n'est pas encore un groupe
mais pour le staff du fn mois on vient
me voir à un moment donné par exemple
ouais charles vient me voir à la sortie
d'une réunion à strasbourg
voilà avec une feuille un papier un
crayon et bien moi qui me dit bon pour
toi on a pensé à huguette or il faut
signer voilà alors je lui dis commence à
huguette dit oui mais on a pensé à
huguette pour toi pour être une
assistons d'assistante hors jeu au début
j'ai cru que c'était une farce
j'ai rien contre cette personne c'est
quelqu'un voilà je côtoyais au fn 14 ans
maintenant donc quelqu'un de gentil
agréable et tout ça mais pour moi elle
n'a pas du tout le profil d'un assistant
parlementaire si vous voulez bon
donc je lui dis donc je ne prendrai pas
huguette alors là bon la mine se
décompose premier acte de résistance
donc ça va pas se passer exactement
comme ils s'imaginent et donc il repart
mais il a mis là il va la placer
ailleurs avec ne voulait pas d'une
gaieté
elle partira ainsi voilà vous a proposé
qu' après mais après on n'est pas trop
venu me propos de sujets qui sont pas
passés non piges je me suis mis très
comment dire s'ils approuvent et très
peu pas inventé sophie ce que raconte la
gelée écrit dans mon livre voilà 2019
c'est aussi bien sûr sa fille il ya pas
eu de procès pour diffamation n'y a pas
eu de la veille après douze ans dans les
salles et non qu'est ce que vous dites
les abonnements et jolie qu'elle rendra
d'argent qu'un jugement sera rendu
demain qui sera dit qu'elle doit rendre
l'argent c'est un principe légaliste
ultra sam je vais pas chercher ailleurs
aller assez grande pour se défendre tout
seul maintenant mais on est d'accord sur
le fait que la justice dira la justice
passera c'est pas sais pas comment dire
bon je suis pas là mais je suis pas juge
d'instruction 1
encore une fois moi je suis là pour
témoigner pour raconter son vécu ses
seins pense que le système qui a été mis
en place par le front national n'est pas
un système unique et qu'il ya d'autres
partis politiques tient le fond je les
fais j'ai d'ailleurs fait un signalement
pour les autres pour d'autres partis
politiques modem 5 6 me au 2ème tour et
pour la france a soumis ce parce que
c'est des pratiques si vous voulez la
politique ce n'est pas plus blanc que
blanc s'est enfin fo on n'est pas dans
le monde des bisounours
il ya quand même des limites si vous
voulez moi je conserve les rênes c'est
que c'est plus voir les autres mois
l'annoncé pas il n'y a pas que ça qui me
gêne moi profondément c'est que alors
considérons que tout le monde admire est
presque fait que la plupart en mauvaises
pratiques
bon d'accord mais le parti dans lequel
j'ai été pendant un certain nombre
d'années
avais je me souviens avoir défilé à des
premiers mais en braillant t t au t1
propre tous unis tous pourris et tout ça
et à un moment donné il faut quand même
être en adéquation avec son salaire il
faut avoir le cul propre exactement
comment ça il ya un moment donné il faut
être capable de se regarder dans la
glace qui arrêter de donner des leçons
de morale à tout le monde qu'on soit
même on a des pratiques qui sont pas
très metz
voilà c'est là que ça me choque moi
c'est là que ça marche ça m'a
profondément choqué parce que je veux
bien taper sur mes adversaires en
politique je veux bien aller sur le fond
politique mais sur la question des
commandites quand ça pose un problème de
comment dire de 2,2 de détournement de
fonds à la chose comme ça on peut pas on
peut pas donner des leçons de morale à
12 minutes qu'on soit blanc on utilise
ces pratiques la glisse alors jamais ça
non mais c'est baisser je pense que
c'est pire que ça c'est à dire que en
même temps quand on tape sur une
institution en l'occurrence union
européenne en disant c'est le machin
c'est le truc qui font sortir ma chance
et ça en plus dense qu'il faut il faut
et saignements être caressé par ces
pratiques du ambitieux pas alors moi je
sais que ces pratiques sont son répond
et elle était répandu enfin c'est pas
comme disait sophie montel ya un instant
ça concerne pas que il le rassemblement
sable devait effectivement le
rassemblement national sont montés en
épingle et il y a une composante
politique à cette histoire qu'on peut
pas qu'on peut pas nier si vous voulez
on met donc c'est moi je sais ce que je
dénonce c'est le sait ne pas dire tout
le lagoon donc moi aussi je n'en mets
cessez le feu mais là il vient de
reconnaître que le front national l'a
fait pas bien son nom mais moi je moi
j'en sais rien et si vous venez de le
reconnaître ce que je viens de me
connais je dis que si gérard type
politique le modem l'a fait et c'est
tout de suite le oui il ya deux
personnes mais c'est l'opportunisme le
modem moi ce qui me gêne aujourd'hui ils
sont fait bouffer par la république on
marque c'est l'opportunisme pour le
politico judiciaires de cette affaire je
m'affaire a été a été révélée par le
parlement européen en 2014 2015
on vient au jour donc après le parquet
de paris a été saisie je crois en la fin
voilà et donc depuis ça fait donc quatre
ans et on nous ressort aujourd'hui à
quelques mois de l'élection comme ça
c'était passé d'ailleurs bisannuel
c'est le jeu mais je sais c'est quand
même une affaire quand on voit la
fatigue aidant deux oreilles gens mais
ça ça veut dire que le gars tu
magouilles et ouais c'est moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé monter rôle ou de le
sortir maintenant ce que j attendais je
dis que par exemple pour la faire fillon
la sphère fillon elle a été jugée en
deux ans et demi
c'est sabrina pour une à trois pour
quelque chose on est quand même beaucoup
moins voilà beaucoup moins lourd est là
que la sphère des assistants
parlementaires et le cadre de son
émission qu'attend-t-on pour la juger
jeu que je pense qu on la maintient on
maintient cette affaire ouverte alors
qu'elle aurait pu et là ça fait quand
même est-ce que quatre à cinq années qui
s'est ouvert ce fonds sert comme un
mister est sûre la chaque fois les deux
accoudoirs vous avez déjà passé d'accord
par le fait qu'il ya c'est sûr géraldine
non moi effectivement je trouve que
c'est une en fait elle est infiniment
politique parce que de deux choses l'une
ça montre d'abord que la campagne est
lancée ça fait pschitt soit c'est au
contraire ça prend de l'ampleur un peu
comme la sphère fillon et à ce moment là
c'est pour discréditer définitivement
marine le pen qui est la candidate
dangereuse mais pour macron au deuxième
tour
moi ce qu'ils viennent malgré tout dans
ce sort de pluralisme démocratique c'est
que le modèle même si ces morts et ces
exemples aujourd'hui ils l'ont fait la
france a soumis ils l'ont fait et malgré
tout là on montre juste non sur ça je
suis d'accord si la propension même
volume
millions mais parce que le rsa
aujourd'hui c'est plus important de vous
raconter une petite anecdote allergies
fille quand j'ai déposé ce parce que
personne ne voulait le faire moi j'ai un
moment donné je me dis bon alors le
parlement européen nous tombe dessus
reproche aux partis politiques de
prendre des assistants et de commandes
fière d'avoir des gens politisés entre
guillemets je vais voir comment les
autres
les autres députés européens quel est le
profil de leurs assistants donc avec un
de mes assistants à bruxelles on s'amuse
on s'était tous qu'on en fait on a tous
googleliser on appris la liste des
assistants parlementaires de pierpoljak
on à google is et on a vu qu'ils en
avaient un caviar et celui qui a été
vice président d'un conseil régional y
avait celui qu'avait des responsabilités
dans une campagne interne dans une
primaire il y avait la nièce qui avait
il y avait vingt six de suite bon donc
en fait à partir de ça on a monté un
dossier
on a fait un j'ai fait 1 heure personne
ne voulait y aller au front un qu'est ce
que tu veux mais la toile
maintenant ça nous voilà donc résultat
des courses jeux j'y vais je porte les
signalements auprès du procureur
concernant la france est soumise et
concernant le modem se troue se passe
l'élection donc ça c'était au moment de
la présidentielle en mars 2017
j'apprends en mai 2010 est ça a été très
rapide que le parquet ouvre une enquête
et à ce moment là tout le monde ment
comme encadré mans tout en me disant bon
alors tu fais attention à ce que tu
racontes tout macron venait venait
d'être élu président et venait de nommer
monsieur bayrou garde des sceaux donc et
à l'époque vous souvenez il y avait
cette histoire de loi sur la
moralisation et la vie peu de
renseignements et donc les chefs de
partis politiques sont invités par le
garde des sceaux a discuté et moi je me
revois encore donc j'étais dans mon
jardin et avait toute la presse
nationale qui descendait bfm machin c8
enfin tout le monde était descendu pour
pour venir matière view est sûre mais
fameux signalement l ouverture de ces
enquêtes et à un moment donné donc moi
j'explique pourquoi j'ai fait ça pour
lutter contre le deux poids deux mesures
na na nana na na hey un moment donné
donc je reçois un coup de téléphone
quand leurs photos qui me dit écoute
maintenant tu lève le pied que le modem
qui équivaut à florian philippon
m'appelle et me dit lève le pied que le
modèle je suis dit pourquoi je pourquoi
je devrais lever le pied que le modem
il me dit tu dis plus rien je sui bat
angers en cours du journaliste car il
veut paraître comme une carpe et tout ça
dit non mais je t'expliquerai alors je
je pousse le bouchon jerry écoute
florian mais tant qu on veuille bien
compris voilà tu me dis et il m'a dit
bon écoute
elle vient de sortir de chez bayrou et
donc tu lève le pied et après le
chanteur non mais sur twitter on voyait
à part mais dans des conversations parce
que nous avons des conversations privées
non on voit aider des proches de florian
philippot et des assistants du front qui
différent on va vivement qu'on ait une
loi d'exception une loi d'amnistié
générale s'étaient mis d'accord voilà
c'est je sais pas ce qui c'est je suis
bureau et non pas moi je n'ai pas douté
c'est ce que j'allais dire ils ont fait
émerger des arrivants j'imagine que le
sujet d'actualité c'était cette fameuse
ouverture d' enquêtes et les sur ta
données puisque voilà ça ça c'est facile
à faire du temps alors mars 2019 a
lorsqu'il a été lu par un certain nombre
de politiques
personne n'a moufté ah non c'est encore
une fois c'est des choses
alors bon c'est toujours il n'avait
jamais quitté leur n a jamais su ça j'ai
quitté leur haine alors moi j'étais pas
un emploi fictif ou plus être un emploi
fictif alors en sens inverse c'est à
dire je me suis gt1 j'ai eu un
engagement de quatre années complètement
bénévole à auxerre vous étiez pas du
tout pas du tout payer our bon et quand
on s'en sert pour ça qu'en 25 h dans un
parti politique c'est évidemment pour
avoir une investiture qui correspondent
à la fois votre engagement et vos
compétences arelate américaine et
n'ayant n'ayant unis fans ayant eu une
reconnaissance ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre une raison de cela des suivis
rester non je pense que même ma faim
honnêtement ma marine est une personne
que je respecte beaucoup
sauf que son entourage et iai et non son
entourage et dans ses plans non et non
ses conseillers plus influents oui mais
il ya des gens qui ont une appli qui ont
l'ampleur intellectuelle d'un balais
d'essuie glace mais c'est facile c'est
facile c'est elle scelle la présidente
du mouvement
celle-là responsable si elle dit niet à
peu près des roues penser que ça peut
lui faire mal à marine le pen est ce que
ça peut lui côté des sanctions ça non
non non non chose que ce que fin je
pense très sincèrement que voilà pour
l'instant ils sont haut dans les
sondages
moi je suis moins persuadé que ça se
concrétise tous les régionales est juste
en revenir sur ses ressources sur cette
histoire d'abord le l'enquète du jdd là
il n'y a rien de nouveau sous le soleil
parce que le rapport qui est dont il est
fait état dans ces dunes
d'abord c'est un rapport de synthèse
parce qu'il ya un changement de juge et
il ya effectivement un résumé de la
situation qui règne pour le nouveau juge
donc considérer pages qui a un truc
vraiment énorme nouveau qui est d
arriver c'est de la manière pour moi
c'est de c'est de la manipulation la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut pas non
plus perdre de vue l'idée pour ge et je
suis bien placé pour là pour le dire
parce que je les ai vécus l'idée que le
rn a quand même le plus grand mal à
obtenir des financements c'est pas un
parti comme un autre
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit que lorsque
leur baignoire exemple fait ça ou
lorsque la france a soumis ce fait ça
est bien ici l'autre à ce jour ils n'ont
pas vraiment de raison de le faire
bosser des vosges et érigé des candidats
sans j'étais candidat j'ai été candidat
aux élections législatives je devais
ouvrir un compte de campagne
eh bien figurez vous qu après avoir
écumé toutes les banques pour ouvrir mon
compte de campagne
aucune banque n'a fait que les rues de
calais il a fallu que la peau de leiris
oblige une autre une banque française à
m'ouvrir un compte de campagne salaire
était le cas pour percer alors il ya une
chose à préciser
moi j'ai été candidate à de très
nombreuses reprises pour le front
national
je n'ai jamais eu de difficultés pour
ouvrir la l'indre contenir ces gens
visitent les candidats qui dépendaient
de presse qu'il a précisé c'est que au
vu d'un certain nombre d'événements qui
se sont passés au front national
notamment un certain nombre de scandales
financiers et notamment l'histoire des
affaires des assistants parlementaires
effectivement il ya un certain nombre de
deux
deux banques qui ont changé assez
exactement mais ces lignes et a servi à
ça celia sébastien vous posez madame
louis combien l'europe vous donne comme
budget mensuel pour payer vos assistants
et c'est énorme c'est une enveloppe par
députés par mois ces 23 23 mille euros
23000 euros par mois je compte pas ça
fait je vais remettre ça oui c'est ça
sur sur la toya jackson oui c'est par
moi même 3000 euros alors sophie
attendez j'ai l'impression vous avez le
rockeur contre marine le pen alors j'ai
jamais été copine avec marine le pen
donc moi quand tu le changement de
présidence était le choix entre
gollnisch elle ouais donc ça a été vite
pliée si vous voulez je peux penser que
elle elle a amené un vent de modernité
voilà vous voyez on pensait qu'elle fois
depuis 2002 non non ou alors sur un
malentendu comme ils disent à
l'intérieur du front assez bruno bilde
qui a 5 300 experts croient vraiment non
c'est lui qui se marrent et qui nous
sort si de ça à chaque élection en 2006
a annoncé qu'elle peut gagner
je pense que le problème c'est que comme
la situation en france se détériore et
feintool tous les soirs au 20 heures
vous avez un clip de campagne pour
marine le pen un web escaut pensais pas
que maintenant le principal point faible
du rassemblement national c'est marine
le pen non elle peut elle peut devenir
président de la république
voilà vous seriez content ah bah je
préfère effectivement marine le pen
président de la république que manuel
macron sais pas j'ai l'impression qu'ils
manuel mâcon vous quitte plus que marine
le pen vous croyez basescu qui n'ont pas
appelé pour l'instant voilà non mais les
airs et voilà on va voir ce que pensent
et téléspectateurs tiens oui à 37% non à
63 % comme me l'avait dit en tout cas
c'est vrai que moi ce que je retiens de
ce débat c'est ce que vous avez retenu
c'est que si les autres ont fait la même
chose
ils doivent être aussi attaqué il c'est
vrai que là c'est assez bizarre que ça
sorte maintenant aussi mais c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça très au sérieux